Traduttore: Silvia Elisabetta La Penna
Revisore: Anna Ruggiero
'Scotland forever'.
Fu questo il grido di battaglia
dei soldati scozzesi
lanciandosi al galoppo
verso le linee francesi
durante la battaglia di Waterloo
nel 1815
ed è il titolo di questo quadro
che fu dipinto da Lady Butler
circa 70 anni dopo, nel 1881.
Lady Butler, come donna,
non ebbe mai modo
di partecipare
ad una battaglia,
quindi dovette studiare,
dovette documentarsi,
dovette fare ricerca,
perché doveva poter rappresentare
le divise dei soldati
che corrispondessero
a quelle dell'epoca,
dovette studiare l'anatomia
degli animali, dei cavalli
in modo da poterli rappresentare
con questa visuale,
molto particolare, dal davanti,
molto originale.
Grazie al mio lavoro,
ho avuto la possibilità
di rendere omaggio a quest'immagine
probabilmente la più particolare,
celebrata di quell'evento
e che tanto mi ha emozionato
sin da quando ero ragazzino.
Come si diceva,
sono un paleo-illustratore,
ossia un illustratore di quelli
che si occupano di paleontologia,
cioè cercano
attraverso lo studio dei fossili
di rappresentare
il mondo della preistoria.
Come ogni artista,
l'illustratore paleontologico
ha sempre un po' la testa tra le nuvole,
nuvole giurassiche,
devoniane nel mio caso.
Mi piace la natura,
ne sono affascinato,
mi stimola, mi dà tanti spunti
per realizzare le immagini che vedrete.
Però, inevitabilmente, ogni volta
che a me capita di osservare
qualche cosa di naturale,
tendo inevitabilmente a trasformarlo
in qualche cosa di preistorico.
Quando io cammino su un bel prato rasato
e mi trovo davanti una quercia,
ecco, immediatamente tendo
a trasformarla
in una specie di albero gigantesco,
dalle forme particolari,
dall'aspetto inusuale, alieno.
Il prato ovviamente diventa
una distesa acquitrinosa,
ricca di alberi caduti,
di vegetazione rigogliosa.
I cani che stanno correndo
davanti a me
possono tranquillamente essere
dei piccoli carnivori
che si stanno inseguendo,
che si stanno contendendo la preda,
oppure sopra di me passano
i lunghi colli dei sauropodi
che brucano a dieci metri da terra.
E dietro il cespuglio
che si è mosso poco fa
secondo me c'è sicuramente
qualche grosso animale
che sicuramente può saltar fuori
un carnivoro aggressivo.
Il fatto è che nella mia testa
io continuo a cercare di risolvere
il problema che riguarda l'illustrazione
che sto cercando di realizzare
in questi giorni.
Ho studiato molto bene
il soggetto protagonista
del quale ovviamente non ricordo
assolutamente il nome
e che confondo con un altro
che ha anche lui un nome
assolutamente impronunciabile.
Ecco, me lo sono studiato bene
anatomicamente
però non mi piace la postura
che gli ho dato
e per rappresentare meglio l'immagine
sarebbe meglio
che io lo inquadrassi dall'alto
in modo tale da avere una visione precisa
e completa di tutto il paesaggio
e dovrò però spostare l'allosauro
tutto su un lato
in modo da rendere
più equilibrata l'immagine
e poter avere una visuale completa
dello scenario.
Il fatto è che io devo
avere a che fare con i paleontologi.
I paleontologi, i geologi,
sono i miei compagni di viaggio,
sono coloro che mi supervisionano,
quelli che mi danno
tutte le informazioni e le indicazioni
che mi permettono
di realizzare l'illustrazione
arrivando a curare
i minimi dettagli anatomici.
Contemporaneamente però, sono anche
coloro che tendono a imbrigliarmi,
a incanalarmi in uno strettissimo
corridoio artistico
che serve ad evitare che il sottoscritto,
preso dallo slancio
e dal desiderio di rendere
sempre più emozionante
e più particolare l'inquadratura,
rischi di esagerare
e metta i soggetti in posizioni tali
per cui risulterebbero poi
anatomicamente impossibili.
È una specia di CSI
in chiave paleontologica.
Io ho tutti gli elementi che mi servono
per fare la mia ricerca,
ho tutti gli indizi,
ho gli schizzi,
i disegni fatti
da chi mi ha preceduto,
le indicazioni che mi vengono date
da paleontologi e geologi,
i quali nella loro testa
hanno chiarissimo
com'era il mondo preistorico,
perché lo studiano.
Il problema loro
è quello di renderlo visibile
e quindi il mio compito è proprio
quello di cercare di scattare
una sorta di istantanea
del passato profondo.
È un lavoro in continua evoluzione.
Può capitare che l'animale
che tu hai con tanta attenzione studiato,
l'edmontosauro,
di cui hai curato ogni minimo dettaglio,
persino la pelle di cui si conoscono
le impronte,
ecco, salti fuori proprio il giorno prima
che tu stai per consegnare il tuo lavoro,
succede che esce uno studio
che mette in luce un dettaglio anatomico
veramente insignificante
che è una cresta carnosa proprio in mezzo
alla fronte del nostro soggetto,
quindi sarà mia premura quella di cercare
di aggiornare questo animale
alla velocità della luce.
Stessa cosa può succedere,
per esempio,
per un animale
come può essere il tirannosauro.
I tirannosauri sono
tra gli animali preistorici
tra i più conosciuti in assoluto
nel campo della paleontologia.
Ecco, da qualche tempo i paleontologi
sono praticamente convinti
che i tirannosauri fossero coperti
da una sorta di piumaggio primitivo
che si chiamano proto-piume,
quindi una specie di soffice piumino,
il che ovviamente nella mia testa
si è presentato subito
come una specie di gigantesco
pulcino mannaro --
(Risate)
e quindi ho dovuto trasformare
quella vecchia illustrazione
di cui andavo particolarmente fiero
in un qualche cosa che fosse
anatomicamente sistemato --
essendo una cosa vecchia
di qualche anno fa --
fosse anatomicamente sistemato
ma anche ricoperto
di questo piumaggio.
E cosa succede?
Quando ci si trova di fronte
a questo tipo di problematiche
la tecnologia ovviamente diventa
il mezzo fondamentale
perché si possano risolvere
e questo è il motivo per cui
i paleontologi utilizzano i laser scanner
per avere delle immagini
tridimensionali dei reperti
oppure fanno delle TAC
in modo da poter osservare
l'interno del nostro fossile
senza doverlo rompere o tagliare.
Gli illustratori utilizzano Photoshop
con i caratteristici livelli sovrapposti,
mentre le vecchie maquette,
cioè quei modellini fatti in plastilina,
vengono sostituiti dagli scultori
da delle sculture
fatte con i nuovi programmi
di modellazione digitale tridimensionale,
quindi modellazione 3D.
È un lavoro estremamente
complesso, minuzioso,
che deve richiedere
tanta pazienza e dedizione
per cui non è raro
che dopo tanto lavorare
sulla texture di un animale,
il sottoscritto vada a dormire,
chiuda gli occhi
e continui a vedere squame,
squamine, squamette,
punte, artigli, seghettature
e tutto questo genere di cose.
Però una volta raggiunto il proprio scopo,
cioè aver finalmente realizzato
il modello finale,
si aprono degli scenari che possono
dare spunto a delle iniziative
che non sono propriamente scientifiche --
(Risate)
-- e che però danno anche
grande soddisfazione
e divertimento a chi tanto tempo
ha passato su questi soggetti.
I paleontologi hanno a disposizione
del materiale straordinario,
materiale assolutamente incredibile
come è il piccolo 'Ciro',
cioè lo Scipionyx samniticus,
quel piccolo dinosauro
che è stato trovato vicino a Pietraroja
e che è un cucciolo.
Lo sappiamo perché le proporzioni
del corpo ce lo dicono,
la testa molto grande, anzi, gli occhi
molto grandi rispetto alla testa.
C'è addirittura la fontanella aperta,
proprio come i bambini
Sappiamo che cosa ha mangiato
perché la fossilizzazione
è talmente incredibile
che si vedono
persino gli organi interni,
è un caso unico al mondo.
E all'interno di questi organi
sono stati trovate delle zampine
che corrispondono a quelle
di una piccola lucertola.
Sappiamo dove viveva:
in un ambiente simile
a quello delle odierne Bahamas.
Ce lo dicono i sedimenti.
Non sappiamo come è morto,
e questo rimane un mistero,
ma è attraverso
la rappresentazione artistica
che noi possiamo continuare
a sognare, a immaginare
qualche cosa che alla fine
resterà ignoto.
Grazie.
(Applausi)